- I AM HERE
WITH OZAMATAZ BUCKSHANK,
THE ROOKIE
OUT OF STANFORD UNIVERSITY
WHO IS UNDOUBTEDLY THE MVP
OF TODAY'S GAME
WITH AN INTERCEPTION THAT
HE RUNS BACK FOR A TOUCHDOWN
IN THE LAST 30 SECONDS
OF THE CONTEST.
OZAMATAZ, CAN YOU WALK US
THROUGH WHAT HAPPENED
IN THAT LAST PLAY?
IT WAS AMAZING.
- YEAH, WE KNEW WE HAD TO GO
OUT THERE, GIVE 100%,
AND WE EXECUTED.
IT JUST WENT OUR WAY TODAY.
- AND WAS THE QUARTERBACK
GIVING YOU
ANY CLUES TODAY, OZ?
IT LOOKED LIKE YOU KNEW
THAT BALL WAS GONNA BE THERE.
WHAT WAS HAPPENING?
- WE WANTED TO HAVE SOME FUN,
YOU KNOW, EXECUTE.
PLAY ONE QUARTER AT A TIME,
GIVE 100%.
- OH--OKAY, OKAY.
YOU KNOW, LET'S JUST--
LET'S TALK
ABOUT LAST WEEK'S GAME.
YOU GUYS LOST A HEARTBREAKER.
GIVE ME YOUR STATE OF MIND,
THEN VERSUS NOW.
- WE WANTED
TO DO IT PLAY BY PLAY,
GIVE IT 100%,
EXECUTION-WISE.
EXECUTE.
- OKAY.
I'M GONNA ASK YOU SOMETHING
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
THAT'S NOT ABOUT FOOTBALL.
LOOK AT ME, OZ.
JUST LOOK AT ME FOR A SECOND.
I'M GONNA ASK YOU A QUESTION
RIGHT HERE.
THAT A BOY.
SO YOU AND YOUR WIFE
RECENTLY HAD--
RIGHT HERE.
STAY WITH ME.
YOU AND YOUR WIFE
RECENTLY HAD TWINS, OKAY?
HOW DOES IT FEEL
TO BE A NEW DAD?
- YOU KNOW, WE WANTED TO STAY
AS A TEAM, EXECUTE,
GIVE 100%,
PLAY BY PLAY.
- OKAY, YOU KNOW WHAT,
I'M GONNA JUST--I'M JUST GONNA--
I'M GONNA DO A LITTLE TEST
RIGHT NOW.
HEY, OZ, HOW'D YOU GET
TO THE GAME TODAY?
- THEY A GOOD TEAM,
GREAT TEAM, 100%.
- AND WHAT'D YOU HAVE
FOR DINNER LAST NIGHT?
- 100%.
- 100%. YEAH, YOU DID.
OF COURSE.
100% OF WHATEVER 100% WAS.
YOU KNOW WHAT,
CAN YOU JUST DO ME A FAVOR
AND TELL ME
ONE SPECIFIC THING?
LIKE, JUST ONE ACTUAL, ORIGINAL
OBSERVATION THAT YOU HAD
ABOUT TODAY'S GAME?
THE GAME THAT YOU WON
ALMOST SINGLE-HANDEDLY.
DO YOU THINK
THAT YOU COULD DO THAT, OZ?
- OH, 100%.
- OH, GOD DAMN IT!